[Music]
again quick reminder thursday september
24th at 7 p.m we're going to be doing a
live show
are you garbage at the punch line in
philadelphia pennsylvania come and check
us out
yeah guys it's going to be a good show
we're going to do a live stand up and a
live podcast with special guest
mike rainey from dadmy podcast so check
it out get your tickets
now yes sir hey gang it's your old pals
uncle hank and kippy just want to thank
you for tuning in to
ru garbage yeah guys make sure you
subscribe
that way you get the episode as they
come out you can also go to gas
digitalnetwork.com use promo code ayg
to get bonus content and get the
episodes before they come out and
hd streaming do it yeah
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley
oh baby hey everybody out there welcome
back to everybody's favorite new podcast
this is ru garbage the show where we sit
down with your favorite comedians
and find if they go up classy or if
they're absolute trash
i'm your host dave foley coming at you
on a beautiful day here at gas digital
studios
the heart of the east village new york
city alive and well
back in the new york groove feeling good
the falls [ __ ] coming in
get the [ __ ] pumpkin pie ready
because uncle hank
is hungry my co-host coming at you from
right next to me
he's the brains behind the operation
ladies and gentlemen you know him you
love him
do yourself a favor gang the next time
you're reaching for a best pal
you go ahead and make it a kippy he's on
sale right now half price
give it up for kevin james ryan
everybody forty percent more forehead
and get it while it lasts everybody
happy to be now
happy to be here thanks so much for
listening everybody couple of quick
announcements get the business out of
the way
live show philadelphia live podcast and
stand-up show
that's the philadelphia punch line
thursday september 24th
at 7 00 p.m get tickets now they will
sell out get them at the punch lines uh
website tickets we'll saw it's going to
be outside socially distance all the
good
business they're doing it real well down
there yup um also make sure you review
subscribe on itunes also full video
available on youtube you can subscribe
there as well
get it do it done it love it and that
show's going to have a little stand up
mixed in
with a live podcast with philadelphia's
own mike rainey so like hippie said make
sure you get your tickets
and let's have a [ __ ] great time but
that's neither here nor there ladies and
gentlemen
because we could not be more excited to
have our incredible hot ones
here with us today this kid's hot he's a
[ __ ]
get we got him he's in studio we are
excited
he is incredibly successful stand-up
comedian director filmmaker
and producer all right check this out
he is the creator the star and
showrunner of the digital series
tyronitopia and that guy and the tv
series
ryan long is challenged he has two
stand-up specials out
seen him on mtv nbc netflix he was
nominated for director of the year
at the notable awards his youtube
channel
you ready check out these numbers 177
000 subscribers wow his videos on social
media and youtube
have millions upon millions of views
ladies and gentlemen
he's a tall drink of water he's a
[ __ ] good-looking kid
he looks like the bass player from the
strokes i'll tell you that right now
right this guy's calvin klein sheik all
day he's good
the big question about his mind today is
he garbage that i don't know
but he's [ __ ] cool as [ __ ] i'll tell
you that he looks like the guy that used
to babysit or used to date my babysitter
ladies and gentlemen give it up for mr
ryan long everybody yeah
thank you thank you what an intro buddy
look at you coming at you from the other
side of the table
actually i just realized that uh as
we're talking about if i'm garbage that
i just took my gun
what the [ __ ] rested it on my phone
that's awesome
that's next level trash yeah as you were
like is this guy garbage
i'm telling people you're going to walk
into the canned film festival meanwhile
you're sticking your gum under the table
what the [ __ ] that's a real cool guy
moving wow that is pretty sweet put it
back you ever
see people put it behind their ear that
was only a day i was only willing
i used to have the spacers so i got the
hole so i rest one in one piece uh one
little uh piece in each of the holes
buddy thank you so much for doing the
show man yeah we made it work i know we
don't we
we almost did it we almost did it a
couple of times it was like
we would like we'd schedule and i'd be
like hey can you do four to be like ah
that's the only time i can't do this
week it was like
yeah to be fair though he was like can
you do four like tonight yeah
i asked him i had to mess with he's
moving and shaking what are you talking
about i asked him at 3 45.
yeah uh tell us the story about how you
grew up you're a canadian guy i am yeah
straight from the suburbs of uh canada
ajax ontario
okay so yeah i grew up in uh
i was like your standard causing trouble
skateboarding
nice i love it i tried to do both of
those very unsuccessfully but yeah
what was the name one of them
unsuccessful what was the name of the
first band
um we had a band called element 113 high
school
and then i had a band called the john
stones and that kind of was like my
whole thing for
a while i woke up so i went to
university in guelph uh i got kicked out
of uh residence in the first month so
that should add to the story
okay what did you kicked out for uh so i
they gave me all these warnings right so
base basically i got kicked out in the
first month so i got
for uh i threw a party on the roof then
we broke our window
and then it's a rock star canadian van
wilder over here
one time we broke into the library in
the middle of the night and then like
threw a party there and slept there on
the floor and they came back in
holy [ __ ] that's [ __ ] cool as [ __ ]
dude i'm very cool
and then i so what happened was this is
when i was like in the band and stuff
and then
they basically banned me from all the
other residences except for mine and
then they banned me from mine too so i
got kicked out of that
lived in my car for about six months so
i feel like i'm i'm
i'm i'm trying to paint the picture but
yeah it wasn't a rolls-royce was it
no i had a caprice classic big body
bends i like it yeah it was pretty fun
until it got cold
so i lived in this caprice classic and
then uh for about
probably a good four months it was
pretty dude i don't know if you know
did your parents know this no i didn't
tell them you guys so you were still
able to go to school yeah i cashed in
all my stuff and then lived in the car
went to a different university like a
lot hung out there on the weekends with
my other friends
and then i was touring a lot with the
band too and then
but the car had no windshield wipers so
in the winter i used to
put a like around like a little half
hockey stick
how canadian you know i'm gonna tape a
rag around it and you have to do it with
your arm
holy [ __ ] i did that dude a car is a
dead giveaway
what like the things you do in your car
yeah yeah it's like an old cop
yeah yeah yeah man yeah but played in
the band for uh ever that was kind of
like i was kind of like my job we had a
successful band in canada
okay because of that i got some tvs
doing like kind of jackass style stuff
okay the show that was like the ryan
longest challenge was just like the
alley g show kind of that sort of stuff
gotcha i started doing stand up 10 years
ago and
uh we've been doing that for the last 10
years and doing tv and making that stuff
and
doing videos and then i moved to america
about a year ago
hell of a time to move here buddy yeah
isn't that crazy i moved to america to
do stand-up comedy
i got into like most of the clubs and
then in four it was here for four months
you know this is how crabby was so i
didn't even get a place yet because i
didn't know where i was going to be most
and stuff like that so wait this is
recent that you moved
you moved down yeah i moved down here
like last september oh my gosh
not crazy i was here for four i was here
for enough but
so i left i have all my stuff in a
storage locker in canada right now
and my car is there i have a car all my
stuff and then i go okay when i get a
place once i got a place i was going to
get a van and drive everything here
and then uh cove it happened so i just i
just i was like all right i guess i'll
buy new stuff i don't have much stuff
that's funny you're like leaving canada
like i'm going off to fulfill my dreams
i'll see you losers later second you
cross the border clock containers
yeah i would say yeah outside of my
house there's like riots every day
yeah things are going great ma things
are going great down here in the big
apple
like america's wild everyone's like it's
not always like this i'm like sure
yeah okay i can't even go back i haven't
gone back because when i left i was like
i'm sure i'll be back all the time and
i haven't gone back once i haven't seen
anyone i don't know if that i don't know
if canada would let you in at this point
right
it's you can go back but they want you
to quarantine for two no one's checking
that [ __ ] no they are
are they well there's two parts of it
one that means i have to go back for
more than two weeks because if you go to
the airport they'll give you the ticket
there and they've given out like over
five thousand tickets apparently oh okay
they call your house there's like an app
they put on your phone it actually is
kind of a whole thing
jesus an app sounds like some comedy
[ __ ] to me
this is america i'll go wherever the
[ __ ] i want i'll drive down to florida
[ __ ] no mass keep it real
dude i did a stand-up at some weird
convention this weekend
and they had name tags and everyone had
a different dot on their name tag based
on whether they want to do handshakes or
not
oh that's so funny well we're living in
a [ __ ] wacky world alert yeah with
the nerdiest [ __ ] ever
one guy wants a high five only i'm only
hugging guys
yeah i had a black dot for i only want
elaborate handshake
it's got to be something special uh what
about growing up how many brothers and
sisters
what your mom and dad do what was the
situation there i got two younger
brothers
and um so my parents got got divorced
when i was like in grade nine
okay so then it was a free-for-all yeah
who did you live with your mom and your
dad
uh mostly my mom but like they lived
kind of close so it was like a little
nice
yeah two christmases yes i got them
playing off each other
oh dude this piece of [ __ ] did the same
thing oh dude if you weren't doing that
you weren't even [ __ ] trying my dad
would come pick me up
on like a two like they lived like a few
minutes from each other so they split
time during the week so
like a few days a week i'd be with my
dad's two days a week i'd be at my mom's
and my dad would always pick us up
at my mom's and i would get in the car
and i would just i would get in the car
like all pissed off like
oh and he'd be like what's wrong my mom
said i couldn't get a bb gun he's like
yeah okay
dude just like right to [ __ ] kmart to
get a red rider or whatever
15. yeah dude that's the i love it when
people are like
i know i'm just kind of messed up
because my parents got divorced you're
like half of the people in the world
yeah yeah exactly yeah yeah
and before that when they were together
traditional single family home
so it's single family like like
everybody always asks that yeah you live
there by yourself
was it like an apartment a condo or like
a sit like yeah yeah i know i lived in
like a normal sub
canada kind of have suburbs differently
like the way that america has suburbs
from my experience maybe i'm wrong it
feels like
suburbs is sort of like the more rich
area right yeah yeah yeah we're in
canada it's almost
not really that's not the case really
like i would say richer people live in
the cities like middle class
and almost there's this i was noticing
this this weekend and america has this
thing where everyone's kind of it's
almost like you're proud of like the
fact you have money
whereas in america in canada you're
almost like embarrassed of it if people
do
so you know yeah it's very like more
modest of a culture like you wouldn't
know really how much money anyone has
and stuff where i grew up and it was all
like this different there wasn't
rich schools and poor schools like
everyone kind of went to the same
schools huh
that's why i was funny very opposite
here yeah well let me tell you something
down here we like to flash a little cash
even if you don't got it dude i was
talking to this guy uh
this weekend of this thing and he was
bragging about like his mom and his
family and i was like that is like the
weirdest [ __ ] to me
what was he bragging about like his
mom's like a senator of some stuff and
he was kind of like someone was talking
about someone being famous he's like oh
my family's kind of famous like he was
yeah that's a piece of [ __ ] yeah dude he
was proud of his like mom's
accomplishments
he's like my mom means that's like
that's like bragging that your friend
has a big dick
dude you should see steve's dick it's
huge i'm his friend
ah that's too funny all right so and
what did your dad do growing up my dad
uh like my family owns a couple like
music stores
okay so it was in the family i always
say that like my dad
my dad's side was kind of like uh you
know like uh
hi like middle like good class like
european people
and my mom's class is like disgusting
irish trash
we're disgusting i restricted welcome to
the family so my mom's side uh there's
four brothers and two of them have died
of heroin overdoses in the last four
years
in the last four years isn't that crazy
that's wild dude that's
that's a [ __ ] anybody's are bad
numbers anybody older than me doing
drugs i'm always like god damn you're
[ __ ]
still [ __ ] doing it at 65. that's
just a part of life at that point they
aren't partying yeah dude
it's not like they're calling their
buddy like you want to split a bag on
friday like
that's a different type of drug they're
not choosing to do drugs dude
i used to talk about this when she when
he died my grandmother was like getting
old and then we didn't tell her that
he was going to die because she was kind
of like on the way up and then she like
didn't die
so she kind of got better a little bit
like where's steve at you're like oh
[ __ ]
dude that's that's his brother's name
it's pretty close but uh that was
straight up in and i was like she's like
where is he we're like that piece of
[ __ ] he never visits anymore oh you
didn't tell her
[ __ ] diabolical it was my mom's
decision the other people were like we
want to tell them i was like you ain't
saying [ __ ]
and they're like all right they should
have talked him up they've been like hey
turned it all around he's [ __ ] yeah
he's out in hollywood
he's he's in the pictures ma he's in the
pictures
yeah he's in the new mar movie coming
out in 2025 hang in there yeah they're
they're pretty trash on that side of the
family so your mom sammy's irish and
your dad's family were they
no no ethnicity like my
great-grandfather fought in the war for
canada that's how
that's out of no ethnicity yeah that's
how bland it is yeah they got i don't
know whatever if you go back it's like
probably europe
yeah northern europe like they've never
put it this way i have no idea
how they got here or who came or you
know what i mean
that's never been talked about yeah
that's old school i like that
that was back so far that that just goes
that far because it hasn't been there
yeah it's just like stick and move
that's in the past is the past we're
looking forward let's [ __ ]
go those those [ __ ] can't do
shame
and keep it moving holy [ __ ]
all right so we got a little picture
here so you would say growing up before
ninth grade
pretty like you said picturesque
suburban lifestyle
yeah do you mean my brothers it was like
it was one of those things like me and
my brothers were kind of like nightmares
but it wasn't really their fault
if that makes sense sure sure i mean
yeah they didn't really do anything good
they were like
pretty good parents my dad was big into
like you playing hockey and you want to
be the coach and all that kind of stuff
yeah mom's like normal kind of
stereotypical [ __ ] yeah but i think it's
just after a while you just kind of were
like
yeah but you could become like
especially in the suburbs it's like
there's a lot of boredom
yeah you know what i mean there's like
yeah you just become like a [ __ ] kid
you know just like oh we're gonna go
[ __ ] smash a mailbox or whatever the
[ __ ] it is
yeah yeah and it's not yeah it's set a
fire in the woods or just whatever the
[ __ ] that's just what you did yeah yeah
yeah
supposed to have this job we used to egg
this guy's house so much like the joke
was they had a permanent window washer
yeah
i was just telling that story we did the
same thing we egged this kid's car
yeah daily for like three years yeah
dude to the point where like he was late
for school because he had
he got like suspended because he had to
wash his car every morning
but there's nothing else to do so you
just [ __ ] around i know and i like the
way you phrased that because i look back
on it too and it's like me and my
brother you know we were close in age we
were both you know athletic and we were
[ __ ] you know
type a or whatever alphas and we put my
mind
type 2 what's up
shout out to lipitor um and
like we were like not bad kids like you
know robbing anybody
but like we were just bad yeah and when
you look back on it like i remember like
you know the teenaged angst but then i
look back on it now and i'm like
i didn't have any [ __ ] angst like why
was that like why are we such pieces of
[ __ ]
we thought it was funny i mean yeah dude
especially how old are you
um i'm 35. yeah so like jackass hit
around that time so i was like huge into
dude tom green was like tom green was
probably yeah
yeah oh you canadian kids listen up
they're [ __ ]
[ __ ] with your parents uh uh you
painting like you're painting a dick on
your dad's car
dude yeah that's why when parents stuff
it's like when people care about their
i'd
they could have died i would have
noticed you know what i mean like now
obviously
that you know you wouldn't want that but
like i remember my mom was like you know
me and your dad are getting divorced
doesn't mean we love you any less i'm
like what
you love me less what the [ __ ] i can i
can still i can still put ted in a
shopping cart and push him into a bush
right i don't care if he can do it okay
love me less i didn't think of it until
now why the [ __ ] you bringing that up
you guys still together
oh he's still here [ __ ] well i care what
you guys are here
dude i was just saying i was just
talking to my mom about this last
weekend because like now i'm married and
my wife's like
so what's your mom doing i'm like i
don't know did she call i don't [ __ ]
know what she's doing i'm like i don't i
think i check in like once every six
weeks she's like hey everybody you gotta
call your mom
i do i do but like it's never like the
same thing it's never top of mind she'll
be like oh so what's your brother doing
i'm like
yeah he's [ __ ] chilling i guess dude
oh really i know everything they're
doing every second of every day yeah
you're looking for an inheritance you're
making sure
someone croaks trying to keep trying to
keep everything above board i'll be down
to uh rake those leaves in a couple of
weeks ma i love you
well yeah i know i'm i've i've uh i
don't have to do any of the tasks now
that i'm out of country so i've
cracked the code on that there you go
yeah how do you do you think you live
trashy now
like uh like do you think do you do
grassy shitty try to keep it together a
little bit yeah i'm a little trout i
like
i eat trash like that's uh every girl
the person i've ever dated with
like we we went to like the most fancy
restaurant and i like smuggled in vodka
in a water bottle
and she says recently yeah
macaroni and like craft dinner with
macaroni dinner cleaners cut into it and
stuff like that that's
that's been big the past couple of weeks
you eat like a guy in a band
yeah in a band and put it this way i've
had like
a lot of uh you know times where i like
did had less money and now i got some
money and
i've made zero changes yeah that's trash
i didn't dress differently i wouldn't
buy a new car i wouldn't buy a new thing
i don't do nothing differently do you
have your own place now do you have
roommates no i got a one bedroom in east
village
nice is the bed in the corner of the
room uh yeah
it's trash that is a truck yeah do what
is it a queen or is it a single uh it's
i have like a queen
is it on the floor do you have a bed i
got a bed for him i got the amazon
headboard
uh no it's one of the yes but it's like
the amazon one you know what i mean it's
all in one
yeah yeah yeah yeah i got a chat long as
you got a headboard you got no
headphones yeah yeah no but i've lived
that you know how i'll tell you
something of how trash it was when i
lived in the
i used to live in like the band houses
with like that's what i picture with
no sheets just one blanket holes in the
walls and [ __ ] yeah i was so wrapped up
in that like lifestyle of like you know
being 21 year old
or whatever that i remember a girl being
like when i was like 23 or 24 and she
was
i moved into a different place she was
like oh you know obviously that was bad
and like girls like it's so much better
when you have your own place and i was
like what
like i couldn't believe what she was
talking about i was like i couldn't
believe what i'm hearing right now i
thought girls thought it was sick yeah
this is
wait this isn't [ __ ] awesome dude i
thought i literally thought girls
thought we were like the
coolest yeah i remember like they do
when they're 20 and then when they hit
30 they're like we got to go to like
yeah that's what happened i think i just
dated another but i remember being like
flabberg and then i caught and i'll
click for me like
all the numbers came out all of those
times those girls were disgusted
yeah i thought they thought we were sick
i remember one time in our our main area
the window broke and in winter in canada
and we just didn't fix it for the whole
winter we had a
broken window and girls would come over
and like break their foot on glass and
we'd be like
oh [ __ ] yeah the window broke and they'd
be like broken we know when like we're
like
like a month ago i don't know that's a
testament to your looks they're breaking
they're
cutting their legs nobody's coming to
stay at my house with no windows i'll
tell you that much
yeah the [ __ ] living room's dirty
they're leaving well i mean sometimes we
probably didn't get repeat offenders but
you just didn't probably notice yeah
sure yeah yeah
you're like oh what happened to that
girl i was like i guess i stopped
calling her
she must have moved or sometimes she
left mortified dude deleted your number
i guess she didn't like me peeing in her
purse i don't know what her problem is
did you ever do this i remember back in
the day like when
if if we like bring come back with girls
or whatever and then we wanted to like
we're like oh come back for drinks and
we didn't have drinks
so we would make red bull vodkas but put
no vodka in it
but it was just to like because we
needed an event yeah yeah hey come back
yeah we got it we got vodka they're like
rubbing alcohol and shrimp yeah you just
give them a drink with no alcohol just
so we can pretend we're drinking to like
have an event
i've done that i've done that like yeah
come back we'll drink some at my house
and like i just have like a bottle like
seagram's gin or something i'm like
yeah what do you mix it with like orange
juice or something yeah seagram's in
half and a half what the [ __ ] of water
is my drink though like still to this
day
really yeah one of the reasons was is
because when i was singing
it used to all the other ones are way
better worse for you like uh
beer and pizza anything like that with
carbs when you sleep it's really bad for
you yeah yeah yeah yeah so reflects on
sugar yeah and just like the dehydration
and everything so i i got really into
drinking vodka waters and then i just
like only drink that and like a lot of
it was because of the voice stuff but
that's pretty classy though
oh it's vodka water classic it's not bad
yeah yeah
it's always like papa vodka points in
the good game what kind of vodka
uh just whatever what will you order now
if you go out and you say let me get a
vodka water
what what and then i have a choice and
they say what kind of aki you just say
well whatever
say whatever wellspring if you're doing
well vodka it's pretty tough
zero choice switch to kettle one go
tito's tito's guy do you know what stoli
vodka is yes
i was in one of their commercials back
in the day so like for a couple years i
would i would
like would you tell people that as you
were sipping it oh yeah like yeah i
actually did the commercial
you want to come back hanging out by tv
hoping it comes on
you want to get back to my place and cut
yourself on some glass oh look it's on
tv again
are you playing a vhs right now what's
going on
oh man that's funny he didn't have a
couch but he was in the commercials
though
yeah i had no uh but that works with
that works with women
especially you know in their 20s when
you're like the rock star guy
[ __ ] sliding off my seat right now
what are you talking about he's gorgeous
dude's [ __ ] cool you know what i get
this but it's like the funny part is
it's like i i think
when i started comedy people like oh
this guy's like good looking but like
for
comedy sure yeah you're like a regular
looking guy
in the band he's got the look though
yeah yeah but like no i'm the warp tour
i look like a guy
sure yeah you're just yeah yeah exactly
you could be in the band or you could be
in the audience or you could be a roadie
you
no comedians have actual like identities
you know what i mean it's just like oh
that guy
wears a hoodie and jeans and nikes on
stage like he comes
guys got a [ __ ] nose ring he's got a
look that's like a hey oh my god you
look way more ridiculous i didn't sewn
it down for comedy no the comedian's
gonna have to yeah yeah cause if
something takes away from the joke or
if someone's looking at your wacky hair
or you know one which i had
i toned it back up actually i toned it
like way down and then once i was like a
headliner and doing good and stuff and
kind of had fans yeah you're like i can
i tone it back up but i do realize
you're losing something but you're like
willing to make that sacrifice sure yeah
yeah
leather pants on stage no shirt on and
[ __ ]
no dude even when i wear leather jacket
i notice i do
like four percent worse yeah yeah
because people are like people are like
why is he having a jacket it's [ __ ]
easy
people just once even if somebody as an
audience member checks out for like a
couple of seconds yeah
you know what i mean they're like and
they like don't like it like people are
like what what
is this you're not that much better than
me yeah it's like there's a huge thing
yeah
that's funny leather jacket i love it
all right let's play a little are you
garbage let's do it let's do it
so ryan we're going to ask you a series
of questions we'd like you to answer
them open and honestly
all right if uh sparks any stories
please feel free to elaborate like i
said in the beginning you're you're
amongst garbage so don't worry
no one's here to judge you my chicks
been like hitting me hard on like being
white trash lately yeah yeah they all
have yeah
what is she breaking your balls about
the like food thing is
is one of the main things but then also
like my decor
she's like you just literally like
checked out you literally bought that
bought out the ikea calendar and you
think it's classy yeah yeah oh yeah
that's a real garbage movie you gotta
get a couple of bucks and you're like
yeah i'll get the nightstand that
matches my dresser
and she's like you're garbage i'm like
garbage you know how much that computer
costs yeah that's garbage
you know how much my rims on my car are
right now oh that's too funny all right
so let's go back to the time uh pre
divorce
you guys are you're in your home you're
in canada um
some of the things that we determine
garbage or not uh some basic questions
that we have
uh one would be what was the name of the
street
that you grew up on uh will's drive
not bad middleweight that's pretty good
drive is pretty good
we're looking for cul-de-sac we're
looking for court or if like you grew up
on the off the turnpike or something
that's pretty good
trying to stay away from like you know
douglas throughway things like that
that's what you want to avoid
yeah but drive is pretty that's pretty
good what uh
what was the name of the grocery store
you went to growing up
um i don't get involved with women tasks
i talked to my mom yeah yeah but
probably you know
i grew up in one of those suburbs that
every five years it looked like a
completely different place
like if i go back there now i wouldn't
even recognize for the better for the
worse
it gets souped up now you know yeah yeah
and the demographics change like it's a
it's an entire like when i grew up it
was kind of mostly
black people and white people and then
my brother's seven years older than me
and
his age is like mostly like indian dudes
and like like that's how quickly the
it changes it changes really really
quick so um and then every
places that were just kind of like
subdivisions now they're just you know
big malls and
like yeah so i was there a little
earlier on so
that the grocery store would get changed
like every two years
but it would have been a big it would
have been a like a big name one gotcha
but you might not middle of the road
yeah we probably won't know but what was
the name of it or what was the name of
one of them
use whole foods as a benchmark no lower
than whole foods
okay like a big one where it's like
whole foods are kind of small right like
i'm talking about
a huge oh it's like a big like
strip mall like girl strip mall grocery
store yeah okay okay
was it would you say strip malls would
you say it's like
lower end or would it be like middle of
the road type where where do you think
it leans like what would you
shop there now i'll tell you one thing
that probably would help to
to make the judgment is i didn't know
there were higher class
okay okay okay like to me that i knew
i knew that's what you were getting that
you were [ __ ] dancing around
like when you were like was there was it
i'm like i didn't know there was
different it was trash all right
i'm like there's a higher version i
guess like to me i was like i mean if
you're like a health buff maybe you go
to a different place but i'm like there
was yeah there's the grocery store yeah
oh do you know what no frills is yeah
okay so
it we did my my family didn't go to no
frills okay
so that would have so you were you were
at least in the upper 50 percent
but i went to no frills later in life
sure yeah who was talking about no
thrill was that nate mack
i was talking about somebody okay no
frills is like the real
real yeah bottom of the barrel [ __ ]
yeah they
they're the name they literally have
zero for let's do it
and they make everything they're like oh
here's a ham and a [ __ ] beach towel
what the [ __ ] there's no bag so you
bring your uh food back in cardboard
boxes
we have to pay like 10 cents per
cardboard box that's a tough look
if i ever saw my mom [ __ ] coming from
the back of the car
with [ __ ] cardboard boxes but i'll
tell you i think we just weren't as
close to the no frills
i don't think you think you if you were
if it was gmat like yeah geography
was next door yeah yeah i mean we just i
just went to the one you have
okay ah that's too funny yeah we went to
the grocery store that was closest
okay it happened okay okay okay
um let's see here there was no name we
did like i get my family wasn't like
we're just
like they kind of my dad had like a
company that was doing well but he
didn't
you know he took probably a salary
though you know your normal average
salary my mom didn't work so it's like
we didn't
you know if you asked my dad for money
he was like what do you need five
dollars for like he's
he's sure he's got you that's just how
he is kept his on a tight leash
yeah he's just that guy he's cheap you
know now now that we're all grown up and
gone
he's letting it fly it's cool to see my
parents are doing the same thing oh yeah
as soon as we went to college [ __ ]
things were getting redone added on
pools were getting put in
golden retrievers were getting bought
and trained and all this [ __ ]
yeah he's got a fleet he got like a
second car just for him like he's got
two personal cards and then he got like
a motorcycle
yeah he's got an atv like he's he's soup
and all he's getting atv
yeah dude for like they have a cottage
like with uh my grandparents and stuff
there
but they're uh he's like super super it
up the way he never would ever do it but
this way we played hockey i've never not
had used hockey equipment like okay
or yeah now he's getting like flashy but
he had to do it for himself bought the
oilers
you know what i mean it's like when you
don't want your chick to know that you
got money because then you gotta so
you're like i don't have cash
yeah you gotta eat because yeah the
second you give them a glimpse of what's
there you're like well what the [ __ ]
you know what i mean wow that's a pretty
that's a weird switch on the dichotomy
of canadians i like that yeah so i i had
that with
he had that with everyone like he's like
we don't have cash like that but then
and then what even i'm just pulling out
the [ __ ] jet skis
now that we're all gone but he says he's
like well i didn't have as much money
back right
that's what he says yeah you never know
interesting um did you have a garage
growing up yeah did you have a
refrigerator in that garage
no no my dad's not like a beer guy
okay no he's like a meat freezer
no meat freezer where'd you guys keep
your ice pops the
normal fruits the normal freezer
canadians but a lot of my there it was a
meat freezer area like there was this
this was a big yeah ontario state
sure the bit the basement with the
freezer with all the good [ __ ]
in there yeah we didn't subscribe to
that at the moment
that can go either way because we say
like the old man was tight what the [ __ ]
if you have a fridge in your garage it's
really a trash it's
it's trash genetics american suburbs
because you're going like
oh i can't throw out that no no one goes
and buys a new garage fridge
that's the thing like no one's spending
two grand on the refrigerator for the
garage it's like
you're dead uncles or you find it on the
street or something so it's like oh this
is expensive we gotta
cry we had sort of a mix of like jewish
like monetary sensibilities
with like white trash like existence
capabilities yeah i remember even just
like
you know my dad's the type of guy that
would wear like shorts to like the wrong
event you know what i mean and then get
into an argument at the golf course that
like you're not like what's the problem
yeah yeah he's out there and jeans he's
not like why are you kicking me under
the table to his girlfriend guys yeah
yeah who doesn't get what's going on
he's like [ __ ] i'll tell you
why you're kicking me in because i
remember this what what i say well that
kind of funny when he was at my uncle's
funeral
and uh one of the employees one of the
people that they all like worked
together with
he was in a big circle and uh so he
worked it's his brother but this guy
just works with my uncle
and he died it was up my other uncle on
my dad's side but so he
he's like oh you guys got to see this
guy does the best bubbles from trailer
park boys impression
at the funeral at the funeral and the
guy's like oh steve i don't know
your dad said this my dad's at his
brother's funeral yeah he's like oh you
got to show them it's so funny and he's
kind of like i
i can't like yeah that's [ __ ] cod and
he's like oh come on
and there's like 10 people and my dad's
trying to coax him into
busting out the bubbles impression in
front of like his co-workers like family
talk about being in left field with a
hockey stick do the gilbert godfrey
do the eulogy as gilbert godfrey got it
do it he doesn't give a [ __ ] dude that's
great
talk about it not giving a [ __ ] yeah
he's he's he kind of is one of those
like doesn't give a [ __ ] he's doing got
your nose and [ __ ]
yeah it's kind of like why are you
wearing that why why not what the [ __ ]
what do you care you don't that that
brings up if you had to go to yeah i see
i don't know about you if you have to go
to a wedding tomorrow right
tomorrow you get your own wedding you
have a suit that fits that you can wear
tomorrow
no however okay that's because it's in
my canada stuff fair enough but you own
a suit
yes but that suit is like h m
sure yeah that's fine well that's the
way to go h m suits are like [ __ ] 99
bucks you can buy one every year
however but like there's grown men
walking around here really like to you
know they're like i'd have to go get a
suit tomorrow but it is true because
i've never i'll tell you what i have
done because i know i've never worked
like a normal you know i was in the band
yeah so i've never had like you were
never in a [ __ ] cpa
i've never had a traditional job after
like you know summer jobs
gotcha jobs and stuff like that that
were just like summer kind of things
right but um
the i have been to i have had a few
times where i went to a fancy event and
i borrowed
off of my friend like we met up
beforehand and yeah you know like i hope
this fits like just like crossing your
fingers like
[ __ ] i'm the friend
yeah short pants pink coat i'm showing
up with a beige steve harvey
who's the guy in shoulder pads yeah yeah
the old school suits
and i have to say i just want to bring
this up for garbage purposes it doesn't
matter if the suit
you had as a [ __ ] brunoli or in
armani it
is still in fact oh thank you buddy in a
storage you facility
in canada yes so that's going to be most
of my possessions
yeah but he just said everything's stuck
there i know i got later in
later in my life i kind of got like i
i want to say the girls would probably
disagree but i got
i bought some like paintings they were
500 bucks but now i'm thinking about it
it's like they're skulls and [ __ ]
it's like a skull with a snake coming
out of the eye
that's trash yeah it kind of looks like
a guy that uh you know i had like
guitars on the wall and stuff so it
looks like a guy that was you know a
tattoo artist
do you have guitars on the wall well not
now because once again
everything but i got him up in canada
you should see my storage unit it's
great
what are you talking about yeah i had a
whole mix of stuff i had electric drums
in like my main living room
but yeah you're right the candle just
burning on the table sorry for you guys
in the world
the ultimate okay this is the ultimate
story so
my dad got remarried right i love this
story i always kill him on it too
but he he got married and uh he got
married at the toronto maple leafs game
oh my god hold on right there that
is and they wore hockey jerseys when
they did the vest oh my god
just a big fan you know i got a hell of
a squad this year
isn't that great dude did you go of
course he has my dad's wedding right
that's so funny because
because we do you were a suit to that so
the best part though
no you were a dress shirt but with the
hockey over top and they
so before the wedding they got
everyone's sizes and you've got everyone
got a journey this is the most canadian
trash thing
i've ever heard in my life hold on
though [ __ ] hockey jerseys ain't
[ __ ] cheap this is what my dad said
because i go i was making
fun of him i go to the next wedding he's
going to be in the nascar track like i
was kind of killing him
the white trash he goes white trash you
know what this box caused
yeah that's garbage when you start
quoting the price of your [ __ ] hockey
jersey at your wedding
yeah you're trash i don't know that wait
so that's actually you couldn't fathom
me what are you
kidding me what are you talking about
the [ __ ] leafs what are you talking
about
we got [ __ ] macaroni and hot dog
bites over here
yeah try a slider what do you mean dude
that's a good point though those hockey
jerseys ain't [ __ ] cheap
oh he's talking about the box yeah the
box of the the box that they did it and
they didn't know
they didn't do it in section 202. they
weren't yeah guys this guy's got a
little bit of class he got a [ __ ] box
center ice right before the drop oh my
god dude that's
[ __ ] i mean there's a joke that's not
a joke there's a recurring question that
we
we just asked the [ __ ] last guest if
you had not that you would ever
wear a sports jersey to a wedding but
maybe you would with this family who
knows
but if you had i'm not asking you we
know the answer it's a [ __ ] hockey
jersey
if you had one of the running questions
if you had to wear a sports jersey to a
wedding not that you would ever do that
what would you wear and why
i think you wear a backwards baseball
jersey like tasmanian devil oh there you
go
that's pretty good but the sweat the
[ __ ] hockey sweater makes sense he
did it because you can't get the
collared shirt under it and it comes out
hockey player yeah
man i never thought anybody would have
come to life i'm not so jared campbell
told me this and i'm 90
sure it was alex pavones that did
this but he was at a funeral in the
states and the people gave each other
hugs and said echo birds
and oh yeah yeah yeah dude i yes
as [ __ ] maybe it's more normal but he
told us that story i was like [ __ ]
that's the funniest thing
yeah he also hates philly sure so we
were also at a philly
funeral not too long ago and there was a
guy
there was a guy selling dress shoes in
the back of the funeral it wasn't a high
point
no no lie he's like what size you 11 and
they pulled out a box of jews well you
know what
a lot of people in my family like my dad
has two brothers they
they wear like they gotta wear like a
shirt and tie to work whatever right
and they wear the dress shoes that are
running shoes like they look like dress
shoes
you know those ones that's like dude who
are you
fooling with those things nobody
yeah holy that's a that's a good [ __ ]
those things are always tied too tight
they are um holy [ __ ]
that's a [ __ ] dude getting your dad
getting married at a [ __ ]
hockey was she a big fan too yeah she
likes them too
i don't care how big i don't care if you
own the team you can't do that that's
crazy
it's nuts holy sh that that dude that
just i don't know why i assume you're
gonna go smoking no she wasn't sweating
that one
my mom did the uh when my mom got
married the second time
i she hired me to be the mc not hired me
but
you know center proposal listen mob if
you want me to do an electric slide it's
going to cost me i'll do 10 minutes up
front
but i went i went pretty hard too and i
was like killing i go i started out
being like you know not very many black
people here as requested
my brother's gay right and then he he
kind of went up and he's like
you know welcoming the daughter to the
family and like normally it's just
surrounded by guys in his family so it's
so good to see her here and i was like
came up i'm like first time my brothers
complained about being surrounded by
guys
i was like [ __ ] hold on you're you're
[ __ ] garbage
yeah this is my mom's if you're doing
rickles bits at a wedding yeah i know
that he's relishing in it and his mom's
wedding and the guy's doing pretty good
[Laughter]
dude holy [ __ ] the canadians are playing
a fashion
[ __ ] cheese the [ __ ] going trashy
neighbor to the north
oh yeah no thrills all day i [ __ ]
like it
what about growing up uh growing up what
was the uh what was the lunch situation
at school did you buy your lunch did you
did you pack your lunch
bought lunch up until the divorce and
then it was more of a buy lunch
situation but then everything
for himself i was in high school then
though so
it was kind of yeah it's a little
different at that point yeah we had a
cafeteria in the whole thing but yeah i
mean you don't want to be the guy in
high school
packing him yeah coming with like a
lunch bag yeah that's got to take home
like dude
i had a cool guy imaged up yeah do you
think this guy's bringing his own
[ __ ] lunchbox
if i bring a bag it's my slingshot
my skateboard my radio my butterfly
knife
it's really about me and my music you're
just playing the piano at lunch
playing the keyboard um [ __ ] that i
didn't i didn't give a [ __ ] i was packed
lunch all through senior year
i was oh buddy come on dude nah we were
at cash my dad was a cash
operation every morning hit me with a
five or a 10. i thought i was like a
million
i walked into school thing i was a
[ __ ] wise guy
sometimes like sometimes i'd get a dove
dude i was [ __ ] hey once off pretzel
bam bam bam [ __ ] good night
giving the teachers a soft pretzel guy
there you go yeah yeah you're a good guy
make sure that d plus goes up to a c
minus you know what i mean but fair keep
it fair all right good
um all right i got one food wise when
was the last time you had a hot pocket
oh that's my like body
i'm i love that moment i love that
moment on the podcast
what you just did yeah body
was the last time i didn't have a hot
fighter everything we just talked about
you hear a microwave ding he goes here
dude i'm still on like eating weiner's
raw stuff but though
cold hot dogs hell yeah dude that's
trash kid's a while well you know
a lot of times it's like i'll make a hot
dog and by the way the bun is bread
yeah i'll make the bread hot dog and
it'll be like one for the microwave one
for me
wow that's trash hot pockets stuff like
that and then what just like a slice of
white bread
for the hot dog or what kind of bread i
have like multi-grain bread okay
okay that's a multi-grain bread
apologize
senator wait a minute lord long over
there
hold on the cold one that you eat while
the other ones
right thinking about that do you put
that one in bread or you just eat that
by itself oh that's just a single
he's watching his figure he's got a
tight body on him he can't be eating all
the cards you know
because listen the reason i'm asking
yeah he got it that's a
that's a big snack for me too that's not
like that's a frequent a cold hot dog
yeah dude
because uh a buddy of ours freddy from
philly
all right has been over the summer
posted like a
hot dog cold pie and a couple other
things related to cold hot dogs
and now that you're saying that i might
have to start rethinking this cold hot
dog it's not that bad that's what's
making you rethink cold hot though if
you're thinking about cold hot dogs so
much you need to start re-thinking about
oh he's doing it he's pretty cool man
what do you mean
dude if he's a [ __ ] renegade when he
does it you're just a fat guy waiting
for his food to come out
i i was getting killed i was doing a
podcast with some of my friends in
canada the other day
and they're like dude what are you
eating like are you you've got to be
kidding me you know i guess it was like
for that most trash i was eating
uh actually just hot dog buns but i was
dipping it in salsa
so just i was just dipping listen i've
been in a pinch before i've been in a
pinch you need something to dip
i'm the hey yeah i get it if you're
buying hot if you're buying hot dog buns
to dip in salsa that's one thing
but if you're just making it happen with
whatever you got in the pantry
no more power yeah no you're right that
it was that this was not a or this is
not orchestrated
yeah yeah you weren't like i'm gonna go
get a [ __ ] eight
i'm putting two and two together what do
you got loose buns for doesn't the hot
dogs match up i
very rarely buy buns very rarely
laying around well my my chick went
shopping and she bought
some buns but she was she's trying to
pull him out of this dirt ball [ __ ]
cold hot dog thing talking about one
step at a time getting hot dog buns
that's not exactly classic you know
you know you're but it wasn't no she it
was the bigger hot dog so this was like
not your standard average it was kind of
like
four like a almost sauce almost
infringing on the sausage category
okay you know what i mean so it was sort
of a different it was a different buzz
that these
these were bringing together you're not
talking about like a mayor's potato roll
or anything like that this is like a
little bit more sophisticated this is a
sophisticated this is almost like vendor
quality we're talking about here yeah
all right all right spend some of that
youtube money all right
so hot pockets is a staple that all that
kind of stuff i'm big on like the
microwave dinners the hot pockets like
wait what are you doing pizza
the pizza pockets are huge for me who's
your microwave dinner guy what do you
like
like mickelinas but again like just i
usually just pick the cheapest one
i'm big price oriented in the grocery
store like i just look at the things
what's the cheapest one in my opinion
they're all the same i i catch
and then i'm going like i'm going for
all i'm like i'm sitting there doing
like four minutes of math and i'm like
oh to save 12 cents what the [ __ ] am i
doing i can't tell the difference brain
guy
all the way yeah i'm a different brain
guy it just makes me feel better it
makes me feel less trashy i guess
you know i mean it's funny buying the
like no-name version of things that are
already
insanely cheap like buying a 70-cent
craft dinner instead of the 90s
yeah you're right you're garbage yeah
yeah but i mean i really
it's the same thing no it is way
different dude craft didn't become
crafty because some
schmuck and knock them out like the
parade brand ones they are
or the crazdale or whatever that is i
have a friend jj lieberman he's a comic
in canada and we do a podcast
he goes uh he says he's a foodie like he
and he does like food reviews and all
this stuff
but all he ever does is like talk about
chicken wing places
[Music]
try the [ __ ] homicide wings they cut
the celery this way you've posted like
foodie life and hashtags on foodie on a
thing and it was a buffet and you could
see the green jello cubes in the
background that's [ __ ] talking
about being a foodie
there's a question i haven't thought of
i'm a big fan how do you feel about
jello
i like jello but i don't ever you know
it's not something that i ever have
unless i'm at a place like that if
you're making jello at home and you're
an adult
you're a [ __ ] psycho and i don't go
to buffets really just because i
eat too much and you know i don't like i
try not to like be in that situation
huh i'm a big buffet guy
the best is you ever go to niagara falls
sorry vegas
and they have uh the buffet where you
buy a day pass
oh wow that's fast isn't that great they
give you a wristband for the day pass
for the buffet there i'm like that is
something
i've never you're getting a bracelet for
the [ __ ] buffet
like it's the warped tour yeah yeah you
can get a certain color one i go back in
the kitchen with this one no it's
because these people like kind of like
leave and they sneak back in and they're
like dude it's cool it's like an all-day
buffy they see them like
this is how trashy i am i've never made
it to vegas for one of these uh
famous buffets but i have been to reno
what the [ __ ] are you doing in reno
we went to the golden nugget we went
specific we went out to stay with my
cousins in northern california and lake
tahoe and
we all drove down multiple cars multiple
cars
we drove down to reno to go to the
stadium that's a caravan of garbage
[ __ ] midwest we went to go
specifically for the buffet
at the nugget i mean i don't even know
what to say to that yeah you shocked me
every [ __ ] week
he's seen called hot dogs yeah dude he's
not getting into getting a car with his
family driving a [ __ ] goat
it seems like he's kind of not on our
level food wise like guys like us
no dude yeah let's get out of here you
don't even know what a cheese dream is
probably what's it cheap it's a cheese
dream
okay cheese dream is this some weird
canadian thing ah toast piece of sliced
cheese
and then you melt it in the microwave oh
that's trash
no toaster oven were you a toaster as in
family well it doesn't matter you can
toast the toast however you want that's
a separate part of the equation
sure however you toast the toast as your
business yeah but
i'm not gonna sit here and tell man how
to toast this toast okay once the toast
is toasted
then that's where i come in i'm the
closer okay
were you a craft singles guy oh big
craft singles guys
what kind of cheese were you having in
the house was it just grab singles or
did you have like the deli slice no we
have both yeah yeah you got to have both
yeah people do you ever like the
crackers guys
i could go through it i could definitely
go through a sleeve of crackers
insane how quick i'll mulch a [ __ ]
sleeve of a crack you know what and i'm
going to go back on what i said earlier
in the episode that is one product that
the difference between name brand and
the
legitimately you get a nice ritz like a
[ __ ] gentleman
that's so buttery and delicious you know
what we're really good back in the day
that i haven't seen the toll house
the little like they were like the they
were called clubhouse crackers
crackers well i buy so you know this is
something in new york has that i've
never really seen where
you have all the stands that sell you
know pop
and newspapers or whatever and on the
street right so when i first moved here
almost
every time i would walk by one i would
buy a little
pack of uh the cheese cracker sandwiches
and a diet coke
i was i was working that like i i've
bought 80 of them since i moved here
dude those [ __ ]
sleeve of cheese crackers yeah oh good
and then gold fish inside
good
[ __ ] this guy just became my [ __ ]
hero they're at the goldfish
that's one of those ones that i don't
buy goldfish and popcorn are the two
things i don't buy because like
i can't really be trusted with you like
that you know it's pretty funny we're
bringing a delicacy
we bring it up about name brand i don't
think anybody's ever tried to rip off
the goldfish
nobody can't make a movie that's a good
point dude they got the [ __ ]
pepperidge farm must be [ __ ] tote and
steel because no one's infringing on it
i don't know if they
i something else yeah something's
happening sometimes i feel like they
salt each fish
individually because there is like
there's just the perfect
amount of number of grains of garlic
he's got the jeweler loop in his eye
just dropping [ __ ] singular grains
what there must be
[ __ ] big goldfish lobby or something
dude they got the [ __ ] they got the
market corner
i mean the only one that's close is
cheez-it i mean i mean cheez-its are
good but jesus are good but not not not
here's the difference here's the problem
with cheese it's compared to goldfish
and they're both terrible for you but
cheez-its feel bad for you
yes for some reason the the goldfish
feel a little better
i don't know it's a little bit of a gene
it's cleaner
you know what's not bad though cheez-its
recently came out with the extra toasted
have you seen these no they're they're
all a little more burnt
okay i got a little bit of chard to them
listen get yourself a couple of bucks
together
go hit your local grocer you like your
cheese it's well done
huh like a gentleman yeah i used to say
my
my father it's a big popcorn house that
we come from and uh my father's never
made it through an anthem without
finishing the popcorn
all right let's switch gears uh some
behavioral things
um hot button issue
podcast couple of weeks a lot of [ __ ]
drama on social media people going back
and forth i'm gonna ask you
how do you feel about brushing your
teeth in the shower
i brush my teeth in the shower
exclusively and i'll tell you what i got
uh
um check please here's the thing it's
different because
i do everything in the shower though
shave in the shower the whole all over
i'll give you this but this is a
shave in the shower shave in the shower
yeah i don't care about i it just is
what it is i
like i line up my neck and here in the
shower dessert
in the shower no radio no i just uh no i
go by
radio no i'll tell you what i've got on
that a little
there there was a time in my life [ __ ]
yeah there was whatever you didn't have
a radio in the shower
that's a bachelor move though it's like
that that's almost like you have a
bachelor pad
and you're trying to convince yourself
that you're cool yeah that's exactly
what it is you're trying to go like yeah
i'm cool
you're not i'm not lonely i can't be
alone with my thoughts for six minutes
like it's a party you got music playing
and you're like thinking to yourself
like i'm a cool guy
yeah you're not a cool guy do either you
guys play music when you're in the
bathroom like put like uh
your phone on occasionally i mean not
about
i'm i mean i'm over all that stuff yeah
it's uh i mean i haven't yet but i have
the
what the recommendation i was gonna make
that someone told me and i'm paying it
forward to you guys
electric toothbrush game changer it
changed my whole life it sounds like oh
i'm not an electric toothbrush guy no no
it's a game never look back
the second you do it you go i didn't
know my teeth could be this clean so i
have one so much better
my mouth feels doesn't feel as clean as
when i do the other one
you're using fun dip what
i got one too though i got a sonicare
it's nice but i always find myself going
back to the regular bristles
weird and you know what i was i was
thinking about i did this the other day
do you guys think this is trashy
when i put the jesus christ we're at 51
minutes holy [ __ ] when i put the
toothbrush under the water i take my
thumb and i
i go like that on the bristles is that
bad i don't like you know to clean it
off like this
on your finger no that's gross is it
you're rubbing your finger on your tooth
you're in the shower though you're clean
see ryan long says it's cool that's all
i needed to hear from do you keep your
toothbrush in the shower though yes
what do you mean isn't that better
rather than keeping it where the [ __ ]
area
no some people think it's garbage it's
because of all the droplets
there's a little bit of mold on my teeth
yeah dude if you're cleaning
there's a little bit of black stuff on
the table i'll tell you those
those uh those power ones the electric
toothbrush
the bottom of those things starts
stinking so bad yeah
at all it connects to the charger it's
all disgusting to me i'm sorry
dude you shouldn't be watching i'll
maybe concede
brushing your teeth in the shower maybe
not today but maybe in the future
you have two different things you brush
your teeth and take a shower but all
right so it's
people have uh superficial in a bit of
efficiency it's not because you can only
do that what you can't well you're not
washing your hair and brushing your
teeth at the same time you're doing it
you're just standing there doing this
so what's the difference if you're in
there or out of there well it's grosser
to me do you wash your hair you strike
me as a guy who doesn't wash this
apparently yeah yeah
i used to have like long curly hair and
i'd wash it like i would i send mine to
the dry cleaners
literally once every two months yes
i would do probably got like one or two
pair of jeans just throw them on
whip back the hair throw a t-shirt on
yeah just a chick goodbye
those are efficiency moves though again
like when i was in the band i used to
have a little more like flash to the
outfit
and now it's like black jeans black
t-shirt no thinking it's like kind of a
piece of mind thing
it's like a zucker he's like zuckerberg
over here right now jobs yeah steve jobs
oh he took it from zuckerberg yeah
zuckerberg does it too he made it
zuckerberg wears the same thing every
day
a human head from an old farmer that he
found in oklahoma that's a weird looking
kid right there
he needed facebook to get laid that guy
there's not enough rogaine in the world
to make him look semi-normal
that hairline he's got his [ __ ]
stapled on
all right uh take a full-size pillow on
an airplane
no nothing on the airplane i just i i
just go on the airplane and then make a
note to myself to buy one for next time
do you currently own or have you ever
owned or is it in storage
in canada a samurai sword no no swords
my brother was a big sword guy though
growing up numb chucks chinese stars no
no
no things i was i'm not a big collector
period okay
but yeah that's not into things my
brother is a big sword guy though did uh
did you ever learn how to play the devil
sticks yes
dude i did all of the do you have a zac
yes i i
here's the thing let me have you ever
done karate in public no but you're
putting those are two different
categories
[Laughter]
i was into every trend sure like i was
like i was a double stick a hipster i
did devil sticks yo-yos magic cards like
skateboard like whatever the new thing
was i did it that like wasn't
that wasn't like soccer or football i'm
like i'm the guy out here i got mad i'm
doing the devil sticks
i did those to all of them frisbee what
are we doing now what i was
i was very like what's the new hip thing
i'm i was a
a trend towards devil sticks so they
might make a comeback i feel they might
yeah and then i was the guy like
someone's like i got devil sticks i'm
like you're still doing that where yo
yeah yeah i was a yo-yo the omega yo-yo
shout out to the omego yo-yos
yeah i used to rock that baby to sleep
walk take the dog for a walk you know
what i mean
little fat kid walking around a handful
of goldfish yo-yoing
dude i didn't mix the two okay what
about juggling you ever juggle yeah i
can juggle
yeah pretty good too i got the all of
the things walking on my hands
like but it wasn't just it wasn't just
me it was like my that was a scene like
yeah my whole group of friends it was
always like one thing for a month
another thing for a month like bart
simpson you know
but uh have you ever owned soap shoes no
but that [ __ ] rules dude
soap shoes were like a mix between shoes
and inline
skates so like for like aggressive
inline skaters they had grind plates on
the shoes they look like a pair of
sketchers aggressive
inline skates whatever dude it's worse
than just having like the wheels on your
shoes you legitimately grind the rail
with you like
run up to a thing jump on a rail and you
grind it with there's like a
metal on your shoes it's lower than
rollerblading did i
did i [ __ ] grind a couple of those
benches you did oh you had that i didn't
my buddy had him because like back in
the day before the internet you didn't
know where to get these things like
and he was like the super his dis dance
was just like
there was like a ponzi scheme something
going on they just came up across a
bunch of money
they ended up taking everything but he
would just whatever came out they were
like oh i got a new quad i got a new cut
like they just had all the new cool [ __ ]
he showed up to school one day with
soaps dude i was like take them the [ __ ]
off
right now i'm gonna start grinding some
[ __ ] the soaps are amazing you know what
just reminded me of for some reason like
one of because i guess i was thinking
about my group of friends but
our biggest like pretty trashy uh scam
it was we went to the movies we'd buy
one ticket and someone would go down and
then send it up the elevator to the
escalator to the next person
and then the next person would go down
and send the ticket up the escalator
yeah escalator no no yeah yeah yeah
what you put it on the railing or the
floor on the floor you just put it on
the floor and send it up to the next guy
and then he goes in with the movie with
that ticket and then he sets up that's
good
that's not bad i'll give you [ __ ] all
right for ingenuity on that that's
[ __ ]
ocean's 13. and if you don't feel like
see if there's no elevator if that feels
like too much for you what you do
you have a group of ten people you buy
two tickets one you know
the two guys go in one guy comes out
with two tickets you go back
yeah that's another way it's a longer
burn a longer burn than the elevator you
gotta get there two hours early to get
there i mean i don't recommend on a date
you send it under the ticket
listen babe sit here don't act normal
okay act like you can't pick out what
snack you want
well yeah you what do you buy snacks at
the theater and you get them before you
go in
and sneak them no i'll buy you see a
theater theater is like my main
thing that i i consider that's my fancy
night right right right right like
i love it like that's the one biggest
this i've never not gone to a movie me
and my chick were looking up
if there are other states we go to a
movie and then we thought i thought we
were like gonna do it and i can't that's
the main thing that i like doing okay so
what's your move what's your snack combo
at the movies
i'm a big popcorn guy malt teasers
sometimes wow
yeah sometimes in the later years i've
gotten into pouring vodka in the diet
coke jesus this guy in his vodka
vodka what's a malt teaser oh
uh like whoppers yeah okay so i guess
like a malt ball maybe we have a
different uh all right maybe it's
canadian tree yeah
fair enough a little bit of maple in
there in the canadian version
but yeah no i'm a big yeah popcorn's the
main one yeah okay that's my main thing
big cherry a lot of time girls would be
like sure let's share popcorn i'm like
yeah probably just get your own
yeah oh big on that
here's one do you use the [ __ ] butter
substitute at the movies into the
popcorn yes that is correct
what are you bringing your own butter
what do you mean no he's saying you can
go for butter or you can get pay 50
cents extra for butter
no oh wait you can wait wait well a lot
of most popcorn places they have butter
or you get the free one oh i didn't know
you could do that i didn't know either
really getting a stick put in there no i
meant oh you bring your own
no i'm not that fat but you bring out
like a little package
he's got a bottle he's got a bottle of
pam no thank you i have my own
no i think it's trash or they would say
it's trashy if you even use that butter
at the movies yeah i use that butter oh
yeah i got a ham on that butter at the
movies
i bring a [ __ ] tupperware whatever
the [ __ ] that is yeah
in my opinion that's the top one best
snack in the world is like
movie popcorn butter popcorn yeah hot
dog they make a nice hot dog
you had a stride in that bag of popcorn
that's unpacked like
cause there's obviously different layers
of the salt and the butter but you hit a
stride at like the [ __ ] top third of
that that's a
okay let me tell you something you
sprinkle a couple of m ms on there
you're in [ __ ] heaven a little sweat
and sweet
and it goes down so easily too it feels
like you're not eating anything too
yeah you're done before the [ __ ]
trailers are over someone told me
someone told me earlier in my life that
it was like not many calories and i'd
like just believe that blinded things oh
yeah and forever
i was like dude there's like no calories
yeah my chick was like 2 500 calories
look at the [ __ ] out of here i remember
like 400
i remember in the 80s them having
commercials where they were pitching
like you know healthy snacks
and popcorn was one of them or try some
popcorn and i'm at home
yeah that was one of the that was one of
the biggest scams they had going i was
trying to convince that was healthy yeah
i bought into it hook line institute i
still believe it
i'm like well it's light so it can't be
that heavy i used to think smart food
you know the white cheddar popcorn
i swear to god for a while in the foley
household
that was [ __ ] healthy it is healthy
and it makes you smarter everybody
everybody [ __ ] knows that dude get
out of here smart food's another
dangerous snack that you don't want
kicking around the house
oh [ __ ] my fingers all caked with
[ __ ] cheese
licking them touching my belly button
what kind of pets did you have growing
up do you ever have a pet bird a lizard
a snake a guinea pig or her look like a
snake guy you have a snake
yeah i could peg you for a snake that or
a tarantula yeah
i'm surprised you don't have a tarantula
on your shoulder right now an arachnid
kind of guy
the brothers had some like rats and
hamsters
what the [ __ ] the dogs for the maine for
dogs
the family no i wasn't a uh personal pet
guy
wait ra you had rats in the house well
it's kind of like a hamster right like
they're cute no
it's not nope not even close
i don't care no it's not it's kind of
that's kind of like a cat what are you
talking about
[Laughter]
all right dog growing up yeah i don't i
don't know if this is trashy or not but
probably lean it on your previous
answers and stories
lay it on i don't have the numbers in
front of me i always felt like this was
a lot
but the like because i was the oldest
like the dog was kind of my dog like i
slept on my bed for sure right
and then the dog died and we got a new
dog the next day
the next day yeah that's like home on
the range
i felt like it was a lot yeah was it a
puppy
yeah we got this was like a part german
shepherd park collie like kind of a
normal dog
and then they got like a great dane
that's moving quick dude
that's like they already had that great
gain in their sights they were waiting
on that dog
it might have been two days like top
still i mean that was crazy like
i always felt like that was weird here's
a real trash thing
suburban trash thing what did you do
with the dog yeah where'd you bury it
i don't know okay that's that means it
got just taken away that's the classic
i think they took it to the vet yeah i
remember my dad
carrying it down to the car oh okay it's
a ghost worst memory
because it died inside so my guess would
be to the vet because i can't imagine he
had like some specific hot spot
do we have a pet cemetery in our
backyard there's about there's
there's three generations of rusties in
my backyard
don't go digging yeah that's [ __ ] try
yeah but you give it to the vet you let
them
i think they just throw it out big
trashies they burn it big trashy
satellite dish in the lawn that's pretty
true
you did yeah do you remember when they
first came out
before they had the small ones like the
ones
took up the entire backyard the big full
dish like before anyone had them holy
[ __ ] it was like
there was always one in the neighborhood
it was but you never knew the kids i
never knew
anybody that lived inside watching tv
i mean dude they were watching [ __ ]
television shows on pluto it wasn't even
they didn't even perfect it that good
you got 13 extra channels
they never worked very it was really
shitty even direct tv is pretty shitty i
don't know how they're still well then
they replace it with you know like it
took
two years for them to replace the one
that was 12 feet with the one that's
like
two and then everyone's like uh you know
you cement it into your
so you basically just have them both now
and one doesn't work that's like dude
that's like a basketball net that's like
in the ground you know what i mean you
can't just take that out and throw it
out
there was no cable you guys didn't have
a cable service out there no i think you
both it's just
that was at one point that was hot it
was it was cool you had to choose like
all the satellite dishes the wave of the
future yeah he's a bit of a gadget guy
yeah yeah yeah that was like betamax vhs
did you move it did it move
automatically
i think it moves had it called the
government to move it
it makes it the airline
[Laughter]
you don't want to bring down a 747 while
you're trying to get the golden girls
what else you got kevin that's it for me
man jesus christ
i gotta say unequivocally home run of an
app
you're pure canadian garbage with honors
with [ __ ] flying colors the dad
getting remarried
my dad got remarried in vegas which i
thought was trashy your dad got
remarried in a [ __ ]
hockey game the all-star so [ __ ]
funny dude
that was fantastic buddy that was
[ __ ] awesome oh thank you so much so
much
anything you want to know before we get
you out of here you know what um
if you live around rhode island me and
justin silver and danny polish
are going to be there uh this thursday
uh my podcast is the boys cast with ryan
long comes out every friday and uh
patreon.com
the boyscast at ryanlongcomedy on
everything and i
release a video every monday morning
yeah you're killing it guys check out
his videos
[ __ ] [ __ ] home run everyone
everyone is fantastic
and almost everyone goes viral they're
[ __ ] very funny um
check out all his [ __ ] please thank you
um as far as us check me out at cameron
comedy on all social media
the live show in philly at the punch
line let's go baby
[ __ ] show move some [ __ ] tickets
get the ticks trying to hit a bonus
[Laughter]
t-shirt money's running out yeah uh guy
and then make sure you rate review
subscribe on itunes and full video
available on youtube you can subscribe
there as well
yeah so and also check out the new clips
channel on youtube yeah we just launched
a youtube's clip channel to just be
highlights of the
of the um of the episodes yes sir you
guys are awesome uh nhfoliance on
twitter and foldigrams on instagram
just to reiterate what kevin said thank
you so much for everything we love you
guys
and we will uh we'll see you next week
peace